sar you hear about your injury that's
keeping you out of this year's all-star
game it's hard to be on the sidelines a
little bit my injuries are part of the
game so you know I know that better than
anybody but I've had the luxury of being
an all-star now for 11 years in a row so
I played in ten of them so it's not like
it's my first one that I'm missing it so
I'll do my best to try to bring as much
luck and cheering to the Eastern
Conference as much as possible but I'm
just I'm I'm honored to be picked once
again to represent the NBA represent my
family so it's a great honor yeah
seasons do you think you play I don't
know you know that's that's the good
thing about it you know each years you
just feel different and I think you want
to play the game obviously as long as
your body lets you but also as long as
you have the love and the
competitiveness and the will to you know
to want to go out there and do it so
I've been blessed I've had an
unbelievable career so far to this point
and I just want to continue to add to
that you know I it's clear that you're
gonna have a life after basketball I
know you're already working on that life
out with some endorsement deals numerous
brands that you're working with you've
just added Lowe how does that fit into
your business model and what you want to
accomplish I mean it fits perfectly I
think the things that I look for and I
want to be associated with brands that
is Authentics is where I am and my
beliefs and ooblar is that and they and
they do that I believe in family you
know Oh blowers like family they believe
in the same I believe in charity
I believe in get him back and who goes
the same way so they sold me over the
first meeting you know to really being a
bass of this brand it's been an
unbelievable relationship something that
goes way beyond sports so I'm just I'm
just happy to be you know a part of it
and you know want to continue to do
great things and continue to grow this
brand as much as possible
staying in fashion Kanye West is
scheduled to unveil his new show shoe I
should say with adidas we were just
talking about that how important do you
think a celebrity is to a brand least
I think it's important yeah I don't I
don't I'm not sending this needed for a
Brendon succeed but I think it helps you
know I obviously you know nowadays been
a celebrity being known you know in the
social media world that we live in your
watch and everything that you do is
talked about good or bad but you know it
brings a lot of tension to to what
you're doing and what's your part of so
I think it's just more attention now on
celebrities and you know they are part
of different brands it just in heightens
that you know even more so obviously I
think it's a great thing it's more
endorsements absolutely any sense of how
the Adidas shoe is gonna do well he has
a he has you know already have
unbelievable backing and following from
what he's done with his previous two
shoes with Nike so I think he's gonna do
great everyone's anticipating everyone's
excited about you know you know what
this guy brings to the fashion world so
I mean I think it's cool a guy from
Chicago my route for him from afar and
for him to have control creative control
of a brand the way that he has I think
it's very cool and it's exciting and it
continues to give myself and other guys
different levels and places that we can
go as well I let me let me ask you about
an issue that we've been talking about a
lot on the street smart and that's the
question of the n-c-double-a and whether
or not these players these kids that are
they're going to school and effectively
working full-time for the school by
playing are they getting enough do they
need to be paid you know that's
obviously I would be biased because I
you know I'm an athlete and you know I
understand the struggle you know as the
collegiate athlete as well but I do also
you know I am in a business world so I
understand that it's not as easy as just
saying let's let's pay them it's a lot
that goes into that so I think that you
know the right people need to get in the
room and figure something out because
there's so many cases where a lot of
athletes are getting in trouble for
things that could be taken care of you
know if it was some kind of payment that
could have you know individuals live
I mean obviously we all notice a lot of
money being brought into these colleges
because of sports program so when you
think about your college career joined
when you think about when you played was
it any different than then praying in
the playing in the pro leagues I mean is
is different yeah it's very it is hard
of me obviously no I'm I'm professional
so this is my job it's to play
basketball and be great at it but in
college you got to do way more than that
you need to be great you know a
basketball you have to go to school I
had a family I had a you know I had I
was I was married at a time I had a kid
so I had a lot going on I know in
college trying to juggle everything I
had to keep up a certain GPA you know
just a lot of things so it's very tough
no no I'm not saying that it's not
suffering things in the world to do at
all it is but I do think that it should
be you know some thoughts some real
serious thought about what's the next
you know evolution for college
basketball well good luck with who blow
thank you very much for joining us we
hope you get over that injury soon good
luck with the rest of the season Dwyane
Wade